good evening and welcome to the central
area planning committee meeting on
wednesday the 16th of march 2022
my name is councillor kevin lagan and
i'm the chair of this committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as a recording and by being
present in the meeting you're given your
consent to be recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones
therefore can i ask you when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda paper
regarding the different levels in the
chamber which seems to have been fixed
and and please be aware of an event of a
fire please exit by the fire exits marks
with the green running man
berna could i have apologies for absence
please
thank you chairman we've received
apologies for absence from councillors
anne biel
maize
and stilts
thank you very much bernar
moving on the minutes of the previous
meeting it is recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 27th
of january 2022 found on pages 7 to 12
are approved as a true and accurate
record i say move do i have a seconder
for that motion councillor nan
thank you council alan
can we agree those minutes by sent
members
thank you members
declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disposable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs six to eight inclusive of the
code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become available uh
sorry my apologies as soon as they
become aware and should need to the need
arise throughout the meeting do i have
any declarations of interest
counselor
very much indeed council shawnee
no others
okay so we move on to uh agenda item
five
which is twenty one slash zero one two
eight three slash full
new lodge dikes chase more than essex
cm96hp
miss bowles could you please present the
report
thank you
the planning position is sought for the
demolition of an existing garage and the
erection of a new dwelling
we've got the location plan
and the site currently forms part of the
residential cartilage of new lodge which
is located here to the east
we have the existing and proposed block
plans
and see the comparison we've got the
garage building
exist in there and the proposed dwelling
we've got the elevations of the existing
garage
and the proposed elevations of the
dwelling
and as you can see the topography of the
land due to the topography of the land
the front elevation
appears as a chalet bungalow with a room
in the roof
however it is
a three-story dwelling
and we've got the proposed floor plans
and the proposed street scene elevation
the red line shows the road level
here
and whilst the built form at the site
has increased the scout of the proposed
wedding was not considered to be out of
keeping with the existing neighbouring
dwellings
and then here we've got a proposed
street view
the top picture shows the street as
existing and the bottom picture you can
see
the new dwelling has been
added
then we've got photos to the front of
the site
and the neighbouring dwellings
and we've got photos from within the
site where you can see the land slopes
quite severely
and that's the back of the garage you
can see there
apologies
so the application site has previously
been found acceptable for the
development of a dwelling house the
permission was approved in 2010 but has
subsequently expired the sites located
in a sustainable location and the
proposed dwelling have having regard to
the previous level of built form found
acceptable at the site is considered to
have an acceptable visual impact on the
site and surrounding heritage assets
further the dwellings not considered to
detrimentally impact the neighboring
occupiers and would be served by an
acceptable level of immunity space and
car parking provision therefore the
application is recommended for approval
thank you chair
thank you very much indeed hannah
members we have one public participant
the agent mr ransom and in line with the
public participation scheme i now invite
mr ransom to read out his submission
mr ransom if you will come to the the
horseshoe please and choose a microphone
just to let you know you'll have two
minutes to make your case
two minutes started not yet we're just
getting the timer up on i'll let you
know
when you're ready okay thank you uh good
evening councillors and thank you for
the opportunity to speak this evening
um in favor of this application for a
new dwelling at new lodge dikes chase my
name's andrew ransom and i'm the agent
acting on behalf of the applicants mr
tim titchmarsh and mrs joe ward
the committee reports succinctly sets
out the planning merits for the case and
why it should be approved planning
permission so i don't wish to repeat
those comments but rather just highlight
a few pertinent points
by way of background tim and joe have
lived in malden for almost 20 years and
raised their family here
the children have now left home and they
wish to downsize and
um for the next part of their life
adventure wish to self build a new home
together
they have a passion for heritage and
conservation having previously owned a
17th century listed farmhouse and it's
that passion for heritage that's led
them to this project at dykes chase
the application site had a previous
approval for a contemporary home at this
location however tim and joe instead
wanted a design that better reflected
the historic maritime traditions of
malden in the conservation area
using the parameters set by the previous
approval the design and appearance has
moved forward to better reflect the
existing character of malden through the
use of the proposed materials the form
and the detailing
this design has been subject to a
positive and proactive pre-application
discussions with both the council's
planner planners and the conservation
officer
the outcome of these discussions
um has led to refinement to the design
as it is those refinements that um
that are subject to planning application
right now
um tim and joe have also employed
structural engineers and qualified
professionals throughout the project to
better understand understand the
constraints of this unique struct unique
site and to ensure that this new
building would protect the immunity and
neighbours of the neighbors of the
surrounding area
they're very passionate about this house
and this is a project they've been
planning for two years with great
enthusiasm
i hope you can agree that dwelling would
make an attractive addition to doug's
chase and that it's respectful to the
historic setting and i hope that you can
support and approve this application
thank you
thank you mr ransom really perfect
timing
thank you members i now open the debate
and invite you to put any questions or
make any comments you have on the report
and as this is a member calling by
councillor shaunicy i'd like to invite
councillor sean if she wishes to speak
first
thank you very much chairman i
appreciate that
um
first of all i'd just like to
um draw everyone's attention to um
when the young lady sorry um
hannah thank you thank you
um put the um
scene up from from back in the street um
the little outline of the building was
black but i believe it's actually going
to be white painted white in the um
in the text and and so therefore it will
show up much more
right i'd like to draw your attention to
page 15 3.1.1 which is the first
paragraph relating to this proposal
um
and it says the um
the site is to the north of dykes chase
which is accessed off beeley road
it's it's not accessed off billy road
there is only a footpath coming off
billy road
so i think for clarity
that that should be changed thank you
and
and indeed later on in the text it
mentions that there is a footpath going
across the front
of the property and indeed down
towards um billy abbey
the access of course is via dikes chase
stroke lodge road
off london road
and it is indeed i'm
i'm still with 3.1.1 it is indeed right
next to a locally listed heritage
asset
hilly field
and of course the leech memorial garden
just like to emphasize those two points
thank you very much
with reference to d1 of the ldp
this proposal does not enhance the
character and local context nor does it
make a positive contribution in terms of
style scale and proportion
um i mean the the front of it is simply
too tall
as far as landscape setting and skyline
this will have a detrimental impact on
the surrounding area
policy d3
it will be the first building seen from
london road as you turn into
dykes stroke lodge
and therefore i think it will be an
eyesore
relating to h4 of the ldp
this is not effective use of land
5.3.4 on page 20
the shared
concrete frontage with new lodge is very
untidy and does nothing to enhance the
nearby nearby ie next door heritage
asset which is hilly field
have any planning officers visited the
site bearing in mind the heritage assets
5.3.3 on page 19 like lines b4 and 5.
how will this proposal enhance the
special character appearance and setting
of hillyfield's the heritage
asset which is indeed right next door
5.3.11 how can this proposal not be
overly prominent or overbearing to the
site or street scene
thank you chairman that's that's all i
have to say for the moment and thanks
very much indeed um
hannah and alex did you want to answer
any of those now we'll do you want to
come back
um through utah i can confirm i have
visited the site
don't know if we could bring up the
street scene again
i think just for information it's
my understanding is it's to show the
massing and form rather than
the color and overall appearance
so it's more for information only
um
and yeah as you can see that due to the
changes and levels of the site
it would be somewhat obscured from
the most prominent views
in terms of
d3
i would refer to
it has been subject to consultation with
the
heritage specialist
who has recommended no objection subject
to conditions
which officers agree with
taking into account the scale size
location
changes in topography at the site
and
its relationship to other buildings in
the area
thank you council shawnee does that
answer any of your questions
uh thank you chair um i'm conscious that
the site is within the curtilage of one
of the most important parts of the
town's heritage
which is the um anglo-saxon bur
and whenever there's been development
previously in this area
i've always thought that there'd been an
archaeological condition
uh on
the development
but i unless i've missed it i can't see
anything in the documentation
that either references the anglo-saxon
site
or the archaeology or a condition
or indeed
any
consultation
with
the archaeological section of essex
county council within the list of
council teas
remembering of course that our
conservation officer is prime primarily
about built heritage as opposed to
archaeology thank you
thank you counselor
alex
uh thank you for your comments i'm just
going to have a look at our constraints
if you just bear with me
i can confirm in terms of the
archaeology
thank you
so councilon are you saying that with
regard to this application that um
should the
recommendation be be tabled in a moment
you'd like an amendment and an
additional condition if there's no
condition in there
if it proceeds i would most
certainly and not just me but i think
many people would expect there to be
some kind of archaeological
investigation at least a watching brief
as it's within the curtilage of the burr
indeed the term dykes chase is based on
the dyke of the burr
so uh all the sites in beeley road have
had conditions on them london road
uh so i'm a lost to know why there's
been no archaeological
uh consultation or condition
thank you guys
it will have to come back to you on that
one whilst we uh just check the maps if
that's okay
but we we will answer that query
thank you
council heard
um thank you chairman uh yes i've
listened very carefully to uh what has
been said so far
um including the agent um however i do
not agree that it is an attractive
addition
and whether it's in keeping or not i
think is very subjective
i find this
out of character for the area and i
think it will form an incongruous
dominant feature
i don't accept that it's hidden by the
others looking at the the new dwelling i
can see that it's actually higher than
the other ones
so
i think it's a question of
subjectivity
thank you council heard
council swain
thank you mr chairman yes um i am a bit
puzzled about the these
heights figures that have been done
included in the
in the um the write-up that would seem
to be slightly conflicting
um it is
um taller
whatever that means in this um situation
but i'm particularly concerned about how
the height will appear
in the view across the river which is
said to be
of an important
aspect of this whole issue
because of its height and the slope it
presumably wouldn't be actually basked
by even substantial trees
uh
further down the hill
um and um
following on from what council and nana
said about no archaeological view
there's no a statement really
from an environmental and i wonder
who has come to the view which i think
is expressing here that the impact on
the view across the river is is
satisfactory um to my mind this is going
to um stand out
inevitably which is a function of the
height
particularly
um
the one or two comments that are made in
justifying which i find a little bit
weak particularly relating to the nppf
um which i uh in
terms of sustainability and so on i
really find not terribly relevant to an
individual
building
and as uh has been pointed out there's a
reason why it's in dirk's chase i
suppose
um
i would refer to the highways reference
i i can't see how highway is irrelevant
given this is
not a public highway
but my main concern is how this will
impact on the um
the view across from the other side of
the river
thank you council swain could you turn
your microphone off
i wonder who came to that decision thank
you
hannah
through utah um the conservation
specialist um
advised that in his comments there was
also a picture within the design and
access statement which showed
the long view across the conservation
area towards the rear of the site and it
pointed out where the dwelling would be
and it does show it shows the
neighbouring dwelling as well and it is
screened by largely screened by
vegetation so that was um evidenced
within the application and the
conservation officer or specialist has
um
come to that conclusion as well
thank you chair
thank you
does that give you any any satisfaction
councillor swain
yes um
again we're very back to subjectivity
one can accept what conservation officer
says on matters for the built
environment but when it comes to
this kind of
of interpretation um i think um
view is as good as he is
[Music]
but
the
impact is in terms i'm trying to
interpret these heights the actual
height of the building on the downside
is then at 10 meters or more right from
the ground
but part of that is a sort of uh
subterranean or semi semi-basement
scene from up up up the hill
right so it looks
it looks um less height from the front
than it does down the hill is that
yes
you
yeah through utah yes
thank you
members any other any other questions on
the report
casual sean is he thank you could could
i um just make it clear that it is a
private road and so
i'm going back to um councillor spain's
suggestion about um highways comment it
is
absolutely irrelevant
thank you
may i reply regarding the highways um
highways also take into account the
public right of way which i think was
referred to earlier
in addition their consideration is what
impact it would have on the wider public
transport network therefore it doesn't
the impact of the scheme doesn't
a scheme doesn't need to be directly
adjacent to
an adopted road to have such an impact
so that's why they were consulted
thank you
well members we've um
debated and given some very good points
so there is a recommendation oh sorry
counselor land you want to come back
i'm going to struggle to vote on this
unless i know about the archaeology
i was going to do is um apply the
recommendation
um and see if that uh
if that fails or stance
okay good
just gonna have a quick chat
just bear with us members thank you
thank you very tech in relation to the
archaeology um it doesn't appear to be
within it's not designated to fall
within that area
in addition the officer at essex county
council who comments on the application
does go through our weekly list and if
there is any that have
that the officers may have missed she
will pick them up and respond so it
isn't it isn't designated and we haven't
received a response um which would lead
us to believe that it doesn't fall
within the area that's covered by that
thank you chair thank you but the the
statement um disposes we don't believe
it does but we're not 100 sure
if
through chair i believe it would be
designated if it was and we rely on
those maps so i think
confidently say it doesn't fall within
that area thank you thank you very much
no i'm not satisfied thank you i think
would you any other points you want to
make or
i'm staggered if if it's not
an area of archaeological sensitivity
it's the foundation of the town
in the 10th century
so i'm not convinced i'm not satisfied
but
i don't think we're going to be able to
progress
the issue any further tonight thank you
okay thank you very much well members um
sorry councillor swain so ladies and
gentlemen
um
is it is it possible then to put in a
condition about archaeological um
report
archaeological survey during the course
of the work
it is possible but
conditions do need to meet the tests of
being reasonable and necessary
i can have a look at the nppf and see
the guidance on it and i could come back
to you if you just bear with me one
moment
also just to advise that with the 2010
application it appears which was granted
archaeology was not considered to be an
issue just to advice
thank you chair i wasn't a counsellor
then
thank you councillor
um council shawnee
thank you chairman um i completely agree
with councillor
i don't think we can make a decision on
this this evening without this being
fully investigated thank you chairman
thank you councillor sean
i have to advise that
we rely on the data that we have within
our databases which map out things such
as conservation areas
of our designated heritage assets and
that does include archaeological areas
if it doesn't say it's on there and if
the archaeological specialist in place
services for the county council
has not
uh
through their own uh independent
initiative brought it to our attention
then
i don't think it's reasonable for us to
assume that it is within such an area
council assignments appease it
thank you um
i disagree i i really think this needs
to be investigated um the same as i feel
councillor none
does um i mean
we are local people myself councillor
none um some other councillors here
we know what is going on in our area we
know the history of our area far more
than um if i may say the plan
thank you cancer in regard to the
condition
there is a possible argument that there
could be unidentified heritage assets
beneath the sites
um
it would be
highly unusual but
um
there can be instances where you have
unidentified heritage assets
in such in such circumstances there may
be
a justification for such a condition
um
as i've previously advised um
well let me just have a look at the map
bear with me
um
just last one
one more time
whether a condition is possible or not
if something could be included as an
informative wouldn't you
thank you
an informative wouldn't have um would
simply be for information only so if we
consider it to be fundamental then
um
such a condition would be required you
wouldn't have
the type of force that you might be
seeking
thank you
members i think that we've debated the
the issue
in depth and there are some concerns so
i'm minded to go to the recommendation
and take a vote on that if it's seconded
if the recommendation fails as always
then we'll come back and
reassess the uh situation
have you anything else to add alex
anything else to it
no please thank you members
would you be satisfied with this if we
proceeded to the recommendation
yep okay so the recommendation one is
approved subject to legal agreements to
secure the recreational disturbance
avoidance and mitigation strategy the
rams contribution and the conditions as
detailed in section 8 of this report
do i have a secondary
council of swain thank you
so members i need to call for a vote on
the second admotion
so those four
you please raise your hands
three those against
three against
that leaves the chair myself as a
casting vote and haven't listened to the
debate i'm i'm also reminded to to be
against the recommendation
so members that leaves us with a
situation where we need to
come up with another recommendation
counselor heard
um thank you chairman uh i recommend
refusal on the grounds that it is out of
character for the area
and forms an incongruous dominant
feature due to balkan scale and location
in a conservation area
thank you that's my proposal thank you
bernard did you did you catch the new
proposal
yes i did thank you
thank you very much
members uh councillor seancy
i i wonder with the council of health's
permission whether we could mention the
heritage
assets you know i.e hillyfield right
next door to this proposal
um i don't think it would enhance that
at all
and of course the leech memorial garden
is just a stone's throw away thank you
thank you
thank you chairman yes i i'm happy to
include um that that we are concerned
about the inconsistencies
of um of or the lack of information in
relation to the the historical asset
thank you council heard did you catch
that burner
yes lack of information with reference
to the historical
and heritage site
okay thank you is that correct yes yes
that's correct to believe council
council shawnee
so
officers have you any points to make on
that
rendered recommendation
um
just in terms of
if you are minded to refuse scheme
obviously
it's important not
to necessarily put
every heritage assets
in the sort of surround as part of the
reason for refusal we need to be
clear and precise with a reason for
refusal um
so important to identify harm
so that it's defendable appeal
well i would have thought that those um
councillor heard what council had no
table to the beginning for
recommendation um
would carry
a decent amount of weight behind that
for the harm it would cause and um
i think the heritage loss of heritage
asset and i suppose as councillor nana
said until we get to the situation where
we start to look at that we don't really
know what's there
i think perhaps if i could just add to
that chairman
that i think the the harm in building
this would outweigh the benefit of it
thank you counselor
so
berna can you just repeat the motion
that's the recommendation that's been
been put forward please
yes i believe
given um alex's comment in the um
planning officer's comments i think
councillor hart's
proposal to refuse the application on
the basis of
that it is not an attractive feature in
the area will be a dominant
feature on the landscape
and
the and
the harm in building
this
this proposal outweighs the benefit
council heard just just to clarify
although it's that i feel that it's an
unattractive but actually the reason
that i'm that i'm making this proposal
is because i think it is out of
character for the area
thank you counselor castle none
yes sorry to complicate things but i i
i personally wouldn't support an an
objection on the grounds of archaeology
because
archaeology
i i wanted that as a condition
of development so i'm not objecting to
the development on the grounds of
archaeology i think unless i'm putting
words in councillor herd's mouth i think
what he's talking about is the heritage
asset which is next door
which is hillyfield
and the point that councillor swain was
making about this proposal being
dominant
to hillyfield
particularly in terms of its height yes
much better put than i did to councilman
but
that's what we said
a dominant feature
in the landscape was what was mentioned
in the first instance we need to be
clear sorry who is making this proposal
and exactly what this proposal is that's
right council heard is making the
proposal okay
and he in his first proposal he he
mentioned that it was a dominant feature
on the landscape which seems to chime
with what's just been said as well
how how do the planning officers feel uh
about
that as a reason validates planning
reason
yeah i mean it's uh obviously it's a
valid reason um
in the sense that it's suitably
structured obviously
we'll need to identify policies that
it's contrary to
um
in addition um
yeah no i think i think i think as long
as we refer to the correct policies and
as counselor heard flagged up yeah it is
important to point out that
if members are so minded
that
uh
we flag up that the harm
outweighs the benefits and that
in this instance it would need to be
significant harm
because it's contributing to housing and
supply
thank you alex
oh councillor herds made a
recommendation is that recommendation
second counselor shaunicy second the
recommendation
members we move to the vote on the the
amended recommendation could i have a
shower hands for the recommendation
please
that's one two three four four
those against please
there are none and those who wish to
abstain
won
thank you members so that new
recommendation is passed
thank you members thank you officers we
now move on to agenda item number six
which is twenty one slash zero one three
three four slash ful the police station
west square malden essex cm nine five
miss bowles could you please uh present
the report on this issue thank you
thank you chair
so planning permission is sought for the
change of use of the former police
station to use
i'll just pause the meeting apologies
i'll just assist um remember the public
on the way out remote
planning permission is sought for the
change of use of former police station
to use class e g offices
we've got the location and block plan
the existing elevations there are no
external alterations proposed to the
building itself
we've got the existing
ground first floor and basement level
there's also no
alterations proposed to the basement
level
so we've got the proposed
ground floor plan the only external
alteration is the addition of the cycle
store to the rear of the building and as
you can see in the corner it will
and that the details have been provided
and that's what it's proposed to look
like
it is shielded from
any public views
and then we've got the proposed first
floor plan
and then we've got photographs of the
area surrounding the site
and photos of the site itself
the proposed change of use of the
currently vacant building is considered
to have a have an acceptable visual
impact on the site and surrounding
conservation area
and the residential immunity of the
adjacent dwellings
whilst the proposal conflicts with
criteria two of policy e3 the benefits
of the scheme are considered to outweigh
this conflict the proposed development
would bring a building which is a
non-designated heritage asset in a
prominent town centre location back into
a viable use
and the support towards employment
generation proposals is prominent within
the ldp and the mppf therefore the
proposal is recommended for approval
thank you chair thank you hannah um
members um
i'd like to open the debate uh council
thank you um chair well i i certainly
welcome
the conversion of this to officers on
the basis that there will be no
external alterations
to
what okay isn't a designated heritage
asset that is the gateway to the town
and is a part of the town's history
however hannah mentioned through huge
air
that there would be no internal
alterations in the basement
but when i look at the
document the proposal seems to include
at 3.1.5
the demolition of the cells
thank you
and figured out one moment let me just
double check there
that's 3.1.5
i think you can answer that one
through utah the cells are located on
the ground floor
thank you thank you catalan
so they sorry they they are to be
demolished
they are to be demolished yes but they
are located on the ground floor not the
basement level thank you
um through you chair i
personally
would like to see the retention of the
cells as part of the integral story of
the building
thank you
unfortunately due to the designation of
the building not being a statutory
listed building
we do not have control over
internal works such as the prevention of
the demolition of that part of the
building
thank you
now despite it being listed by malden
district council as a heritage asset
indeed unfortunately it doesn't carry
the legal weight of a statutory listed
building
no comment thank you thank you
councillor none counselor heard
well it's rare that i disagree with the
council nun but i don't mourn the loss
of the cells i i know the building
extremely well i've never spent a night
in the cells
however i do know them and i know that
they were used
mainly for storage they they're not
really acceptable as office space
uh and like um councillon i really am
delighted uh that something is going to
be done with this this building is a
complete eyesore
as things are at the moment i'm uh
greatly heartened by the fact that
there'll be no external um changes to
that um because i think it is a it is a
building of beauty it does have a lot of
architectural merit
merit
and at the end of the day although it
was a police station it was used as
offices
and it's going to be used as offices
it's not really suitable for
home accommodation uh but i'm i'm
delighted with this
um application and i would certainly
support it
thank you councillor so it wasn't one
night it was a week was it in the sales
back in the day thank you councillor
swain thank you uh thank you
chairman yes um i mean i i can quite
understand that um
the nature of cells don't really lend
themselves to um
office accommodation and um
uh but i was intrigued by the statement
that there's no changes being
made in the basement i does that mean
that they don't intend to use the
basement
um and therefore it is surplus
um
mike i have a point about the
application it's from class e brackets g
um under the old system
i think this is an innovation in it
recently under the old system you could
switch between different parts of class
e
this application would be limited to the
brackets g it couldn't be
um there couldn't be the scope to go to
a different part of class c without
permission
um indeed class e as you say is a recent
uh innovation within the um what is
allowed as a permitted
change of use which doesn't require
express planning permission
um i believe we have got a condition
which restricts it to office use only is
that correct
which which condition is that
condition number three i believe
restricts it
if weren't this condition
then it would be possible for people to
change within the different parts of
class c even under this new relation so
this is specifically limited to g at the
application
um
yes i think
um
the question of how it was marketed
um the argument is a little bit thin
um it previously rejected on the grounds
it wasn't officially marketed as a
community asset
um i'm not quite sure how you
go about marketing some of these
community assets but
we've sort of reversed our position on
very slim
evidence
my
principal uh concern is not specifically
about this
application so i hope you won't put it
out of order but it's um 5.6.2 where it
refers to vehicle parking standards
and we have this statement that
the vehicle parking is considered
adequate because of the existence of bus
services
and of
car parks in the town there seems to be
slightly
nonsensical because
what matters is what is the position at
the other end of the route that the
office worker has
in other words um
there may be a bus there that may be
parking the town um but
the point is anybody coming in is going
to have to use
um a car park because they
they don't necessarily have access to a
bus route when they're out of town
i mean otherwise i would support anyone
yeah thank you very much indeed castle
thanks
the point
is in regard to obviously it's town
center location which does offer
alternatives to use in a car as a means
of commuting
i i know from personal experience that
there are a number of bus services that
do connect to
uh larger towns and cities in the region
um and there is that opportunity there
which is why we refer to it
thank you
yes chairman but this is the fundamental
i've had fundamental point about this
kind of area where most people do not
cannot really commute like that by bus
and the bounty have to use the car
because where they live
not ex not easily connecting to public
transport groups
we're dealing with what we don't really
know council swain isn't it we don't
know the people who are going to have
used the facility where they're going to
come from how they're going to travel so
it's it's the unknown we can only deal
with what the fact of the matter that's
in front of us
i'd also like to bring
to members attention that
bicycle parking provision is included
with this proposal as another
alternative to the car
thank you um
there's a couple of comments that i have
members if you indulge me one is very
similar to counsellor none although the
cells are not protected
we seem to
be very quick to remove a lot of the
town's history and heritage
um and it's just a shame that these
types of
assets that are there and features that
we might take out now won't be there for
future generations because uh like
council of the heard i've never spent
the night in the cells
and um
it's it's it's the police station and
always will be morton's police station
no matter what it becomes um it was a
wonderful entrance to the town giving
people surety that the town is a safe
place to come and to be welcomed in so
um that's a very much a personal aspect
it'll be lovely if you develop a
turnaround one day and said actually
yeah we'll keep a couple of these things
and we'll we can do we can just do some
some some good to support the second one
is about the chestnut tree i know in the
report that it is in the conservation
area so we don't feel that we need to
condition it i'm always nervous about a
development and a tree
because once we cut it down we didn't
get it back so is it possible that that
could be conditioned
through utah a condition would wouldn't
meet the sixth test because the
protection is covered by other
legislation
and it would be an offense if they were
to
chop it down without
approval right from the council which we
obviously would not give you yeah yeah
thank you thank you very much but the
punitive measures sometimes outweigh the
benefit to others not saying that these
developers would um any other member
castle heard
i'm sorry to come back and have a second
bite at the cherry chairman but uh i
think if you uh if you look at the
building now
uh as it is as it presents itself now
um
it is a real eyesore
and i think that what we've got to bear
in mind is it's a police building
and we now have a police building in
fact it's located within these offices
uh the fact is that malden has grown uh
beyond the capability uh of that
building uh and consequently there needs
to be more room and it needs more room
even here so so the town is actually
outgrown that but as i said i'm
heartened by the fact that it's going to
look the same and remain the same and uh
so i think that the loss of the of
the cells um is
lamentable but i think it's certainly a
price worth paying thank you uh
councillor herd castler edwards
thank you chairman can i just go back to
something that cancer swain was talking
about
5.63
um
it states that there are nine
car parking spaces uh already
delineated
but the recommended sizes are not in
line with uh raiders regulations so will
they be changed
the size of the bays i mean
thank you outsiders
hello
through utah it wasn't considered
necessary to include a condition to
ensure the bays were at the correct size
as there is no requirement for
parking provision
however
it can be included we can ask them to do
the amount of parking spaces to meet the
bay sizes um i believe it would
meet the six tests if if that is
something you wanted to include so we've
got the correct base sizes there
thank you but that will also reduce the
car parking spaces weren't it
that's yes yeah sorry yes yes
yeah
the larger the car parking space the
less space other spaces unfortunately
thank you
councillor shawnee and then councillor
anne
um thank you chairman um
in principle i do agree with this
proposal um this evening
but i too am rather concerned about the
um the sales um
and counseling allen council heard uh
may um put us straight on this whether
there
is some sort of historical document
about the cells
because at the very least that would be
something um and
something that malden could hold on to
um
they're not getting back to me so
perhaps perhaps there isn't um and um
and so it and if not i think that would
be um a way to go um should this
proposal go through as it is thank you
chairman thank you so much
councilman you were next
yeah just um if you wouldn't mind
humoring me a moment please chad could i
ask councillor heard through you
where are the cells are they on the
ground floor or in the basement
well through you chairman uh they're
actually on the ground floor i think the
bait the only thing i can think of about
the basement must be the tunnel that
goes through to the old court
to the old courthouse
in london
um that's the only basement i know of
yeah picking up on thank you thank you
chair picking up on um what cancer
shawnee said i think it's a really
important point there should be
uh i i don't suppose we can impose this
i'll be told that it's not you know
that's a statutory thing but it'll be
good to have it recorded photographed
absolutely in full agreement with that
is that something we could look at
the condition recording uh the history
of psych yes could meet the tests of
reasonableness
an informative could also be attached
advising of
the historical importance of the cells
i also want to say that in terms of
sales the
uh the council's
heritage specialists did take it into
account and advised regret but overall
uh concluded
that the scheme would be
acceptable thank you
that's the herd
i'm sorry this would be the last time i
last time i speak that's fine i mean
the fact that nothing is changing on the
outside means that we've already got the
word police
right in front so you can see that over
the door so that already delineates that
as as a police building
as i say certainly the cells have no
architectural merit at all
just a plain brick
small storeroom that's all they would be
well i think one of the things about art
counselor he's very subjective isn't it
yeah
so what's one one person's beauty is
another person's eyesore
we've debated this well members and i
think i'd like to pick up on on the um
potential putting the conditioning
um to
to capture the heritage of the cells and
the tunnel if we could do that uh
remembers um pleased that we could come
up with a condition for that
yes that would be fine we could have a
uh i mean i'm not a heritage specialist
so i would might have to consult uh our
heritage specialist on that but it would
it could read along the lines of
prior to
the implementation of the works
a record is taken
of the layout
and the historic fabric within the
building
having said that
one thing i am mindful of is that this
application is for a change of use and
the development
would not technically occur until the
change use has actually happened
so
in fact um can i just liaise with the
planning officer
let's be with his members and members of
the public please
if it's okay with you chair we can
defer the matter of conditions or
agreement with yourself once we have
drafted them
we will
need to give consideration
uh
to this particular condition that is
suggested the reason i'm flagging that
up is because change of use is slightly
different to
development that involves building work
because with building work the trigger
can be as simple as something like
demolition and therefore
um
can be controlled more easily in terms
of timings
whereas with this change of use
um we would need to look at
where the timings could start in terms
of
recording this history
i'm happy with that the members in
agreement with that but obviously liaise
with members as well because our
courtesy and respect for the knowledge
we have in the room
yeah okay thank you so we have a we have
a recommendation on the table
um the recommendations has approved
subject conditions as detailed in
section 8 of this report but we're going
to
not um approve the conditions we're
going to defer the conditions
so
we would
talk about that
sorry you're just going to defer the
condition around the record of the
historical fabric of the building but
the other conditions can be approved
tonight you're just going to delegate
the one condition around the
recording of the fabric of the building
to officers in consultation with the
chairman but the rest can be approved
tonight
yep members happy yeah we'll go yes
please burner
yes thank you
that's lovely so members we is that
clear on that that recommendation is
here do we have a second for that
recommendation
we have we have a 50 of them
i've got the
i saw your hand through the glint of my
rugby eye
members could i would you agree that by
a cent or would you like to show our
hands on it or
agreed that's agreed by scent burner
thank you
thank you very much members um thanks
again for your due diligence and care in
debating these issues they're absolutely
vital to to preserve what we've got in
the town um we move on members to agenda
item seven which is an appointment of a
vice chairman and before we do the call
for this members um but
can we just agree
at the amendment have we actually
asked the officers
my understanding is we just passed the
proposal with all of the outlying
conditions
with
the exception of the the proposed
condition which will be left to
delegation and agreement with the chair
yeah be with that council this way
so we okay to move on
yep thank you um so again it's inviting
number seven appointment advice chairman
and um members are just before we move
into it i just want to say you know
thank you to all the members here in the
room and those at home that that did
vote for my good self has become chair
of this committee um and as you know i'm
very very keen on
working collaboratively
and we can all sit in this room and
remember the bad days when people were
excluded from committees because of the
political persuasion and i think in
fairness and transparency for for people
of the district
i look at the political makeup
and members and members of the public
now i'm an independent member
but i do feel that we we need to to
share to show transparency and equality
and not go through what we went through
as independence for previous
administrations
so i'd like to move on to the
appointment of the vice chair and from
the chair i'd like to nominate
councillor hubner as vice chair of the
central area planning committee uh can
you need a second of that council none
i think what you say makes um absolute
sense chair and uh i'm really pleased to
see you in the chair as an independent
counsellor
and i admire what you've said i think we
should have balance
and we should
lead this council
from positions like this together and i
would like to second the idea of a
politically balanced uh arrangement even
though planning is not a political issue
as such and i would um i would like to
second your proposal of councillor
hoopner thank you thank you
so members any other nominations
counselor heard
um thank you chairman um
yes i think that uh
i think this nomination uh i i'm very
pleased to see you in the chair but i
think the nomination is completely
illogical
i don't think it's got anything to do
with the politics at all but i think it
is unfair
to expect councillor hubner as a
councillor with nine months experience
to be given the task of
um
a vice chair of this committee
councillor shaughnessy um has six years
experience uh has
and is
a member of this committee and always
has been a member of this committee and
uh so i would i have no hesitation in
recommending that councillor shawnee um
should be vice chair
thank you call for a second
let's go to the redwoods um if i can
come back councillor heard just on on
the statement
i remember back in the bad old days when
we had a plethora of new talent enter
into the chamber uh and some very
seasons heads that the new talent with
the vibrancy and the experience that
they bought
were excluded and while i absolutely
agree that council shawn is a first
class counsellor i think that we don't
really know what somebody can bring to a
position until that person brings to the
position
so members we we have two nominations uh
the first nomination both seconded
so because the first nomination call
from the chair was was the first
nomination i think we should vote on
that one
first of all um if that succeeds or it
succeeds if it fails then we move on to
the second nomination
um
maybe are members happy with that
members i think for this
this
agenda item i think we should call for a
recorded vote is that seconded
the council and unseconded thank you
councillor none so berna if um if we
could do the roll call for the
recommendation for councillor hubner to
be vice chair of the council
not the council he's that's moving him
forward
are you happy for me to call for votes
for both of them in equal measure so
if i if i
i'm happy with that burner that makes
perfect sense being honest yeah yeah
great
thank you thank you thank you uh
chairman members i will call your names
in alphabetical order can you please
state clearly
councillor heudner or councillor
shaughnessy thank you very much starting
with councillor edwards
councillor shawnee
as a head
counselor shawnee
three for casper
and four for councillor shaughnessy
thanks very much berna and i'd like to
congratulate councillor shawnee for
becoming the vice chair of the central
area planning committee
thank you chairman thank you councillor
heard
um i would also uh like to um
pass my commiserations on to councillor
hubner it is certainly nothing political
not at all i think we should work
together and i hope we do
now thank you councillor heard i think
it's absolutely crucial that we don't
make the mistakes of the past because if
we didn't serve the residents well uh in
in that and that guys
um so we move on to uh
gender item number eight there's any
other items of business that the
chairman decides are urgent
there are none
so members um i thank you for your
contributions this evening i now draw
the meeting to a close at 8 33 p.m and
thanks very much and travel safe thank
you
thank you
thank you very much